[Music]
if debugging is the process of removing
software bugs then programming must be
the process of putting them in in most
cases the bugs we introduce are harmless
but sometimes they can cause us to lose
hundreds of millions of dollars in a few
minutes crash airplanes and spaceships
and kill people
today I want to tell you some stories
about the most damaging hacks and bugs
throughout history and explain seven
software security concepts that every
developer should know if you're new here
like and subscribe and check out the
full write-up on bioship i/o there are
billions upon billions of lines of code
in production today around 50 million
lines for Microsoft Windows and over 2
billion lines across all Google services
and within all this code we have
vulnerabilities that have either not yet
been discovered or not yet been fixed
these are known as zero-day
vulnerabilities because as a developer
you have zero days to get it fixed when
a hacker decides to attack this
vulnerability it's known as a zero-day
exploit remember that one time Equifax
had exposed the credit reports of a
hundred and fifty million people that
wasn't the result of a zero-day exploit
it was the result of a known bug and
Apache struts that had already been
fixed weeks ago what sorry guys hackers
apparently from China had been scanning
the web for servers with this
vulnerability they hit the mother lode
with Equifax and extracted sensitive
information over the next 76 days this
breach has cost the company over a
billion dollars and could have been
prevented by installing a simple
security patch being hacked by a known
vulnerability is not uncommon at all in
fact you're likely shipping code with a
lot of known vulnerabilities right now
if you're a j/s developer go into your
project and hit NPM audit it will give
you a breakdown of all the different
ways you can be hacked via your open
source dependencies now there's no
reason to panic if you have hundreds of
high severity alerts the best way to
avoid being hacked is to simply update
your packages but if you truly want to
understand the flaws that are
compromising these packages you should
enroll in the enterprise security course
from angular Academy it's a ten week
long program that will teach you how to
confidently build secure web
applications you'll find the link in the
description and you can use this code to
take $50 off the enrollment price using
components with known vulnerabilities is
one of the most common ways that web
applications get hacked but it's also
very preventable because as you can see
here most of the issues have already
been patched and keep in mind this issue
isn't unique to JavaScript or NPM all
package managers that rely on open
source code face similar issues
so trust nobody and keep your packages
updated but most of all Sammy is my peer
oh wait a second I didn't mean to say
that last part it was somehow injected
into this video back in 2005 a guy named
Sammy used an exploit known as
cross-site scripting to updated users
myspace profile with this text within a
day it had spread to over a million
users
it was mostly harmless but they did a
rest Sammy can victim of a felony and
worst of all took away his internet for
a year a cross-site scripting exploit
occurs when the attacker manages to run
some JavaScript code on a different
users browser there are a few different
ways to achieve this but the most common
way is for the attacker to save the
script in a web applications database
the malicious script will then be
accessed by a different user that will
execute the JavaScript on the client
side device and at that point the
JavaScript code can submit forms click
on buttons on behalf of the logged in
user so how do you avoid cross-site
scripting attacks as a developer
well the attacker first needs to save
some malicious code on your server so
step one is to do some server-side
validation of incoming data if it's
surrounded by script tags you might not
want to save it but let's imagine you
fail to sanitize the incoming data the
attacker still needs a way to run that
script on the client-side device so the
attacker is counting on you to render
out the raw HTML of the script
fortunately modern front-end frameworks
make it really difficult to shoot
yourself in the foot in react for
example if you want to write unsafe code
you have to use this dangerously set
inner HTML prop just to do so
so with cross-site scripting we have
malicious code running on the browser
but it's also possible to run bad code
directly on a database let's go back to
2008 and look at a company named
Heartland Payment Systems a company with
the highest standards and the most
trusted transactions and also a company
if that was the target of one of the
most elaborate and interesting hacks of
all time the attackers first gained
access to the company's databases by
using a technique known as SQL injection
instead of sending the expected data to
the database
they sent raw SQL statements and because
the data was not validated the database
would run this code as if it came from
the developers now this particular
database contain the information that
you would find on the back of a magnetic
strip on a credit card and they use this
stolen data to create counterfeit credit
cards that actually worked it's
estimated that over a hundred million
cards were compromised and
hacker Albert Gonzalez was sentenced to
20 years in prison
injection attacks similar to this effect
many different types of databases if you
use an ORM or object relational mapping
tool for your database you should be
safe from attacks like this but of
course it's always a good idea to
validate your input before it's sent to
your database another very easy way to
create a big problem as a developer is
to expose or leak a sensitive API key
you can think of a private API key as a
username and password and all bundled up
into a single string and it allows your
servers to securely communicate with
paid services like AWS Google cloud and
so on a few years ago I accidentally
leaked my AWS API key and it was almost
really bad I was using the node SDK for
a service that required the API key I
hard-coded the API key directly in a
source code instead of setting it as an
environment variable I then proceeded to
push the source code to a public github
repo a few weeks went by and then all of
a sudden I get a notification from AWS
that I've maxed out my budget when I
logged into my AWS account I had racked
up charges around $5,000 for ec2
instances running all over the world
luckily Amazon was nice enough to refund
those charges but it definitely made me
feel like an idiot
nowadays automatic scanners can often
detect if you have an exposed API key
and email you a notification but github
isn't the only place that you might leak
an API key when you include a private
key in a client-side web or mobile app a
hacker might be able to find it directly
in your source code now if you do end up
with an exposed API key you can fix the
problem by simply rolling it to a new
value and of course we're moving it from
any public repos or source code many
good API s will help you minimize the
damage by allowing you to assign
privileges to a specific API key this
allows you to follow the principle of
least privilege and only give API keys
access to the resources that they
actually need that will mitigate the
amount of damage that can be done if
that key does end up being leaked if we
look at a major cloud provider like AWS
will see that they offer hundreds of
different services and they might be
used by a company with thousands of
employees working on different projects
sharing a single API key that has access
to everything would be a very bad idea
instead the major cloud providers have a
system called i.m which allows you to
create groups or roles for your
organization once you've created a role
can attach a policy to that role to give
it access to a service that it needs
implementing fine-grained access control
over your data is more important than
ever in 2016 an employee of Morrison's
supermarkets in the UK stole the private
data of over 100,000 employees this
rogue employee did it by simply copying
the data onto a USB stick now this is
obviously unethical and illegal on the
employees part but the company itself is
facing a huge lawsuit and the penalties
for data breaches are becoming larger
with laws like GDP are in the EU so the
bottom line here is to always follow the
principle of least privilege when it
comes to accessing your customer or
employee data in speaking of data you
might come across something called the
CIA triad it's a model for data security
that stands for confidentiality
integrity and availability
generally speaking you make data
confidential by implementing user
authentication so only authorized users
can access the data integrity it means
the data can't be accidentally modified
or deleted without the users
authorization but I think the most
interesting question is how do you make
your data highly available in 2018
github survive the biggest DDoS attack
or a distributed denial of service
attack in history
it took github down for less than 10
minutes but that's still a pretty big
deal considering how many people around
the world depend on github at any given
moment a DDoS attack works by flooding a
service with so much traffic that it
just fails to scale and completely stops
working you can see in this chart how
the inbound traffic suddenly spiked but
the server's treated these as legitimate
requests and responded with a normal
response github is big enough to handle
attacks like this but smaller sites
might not be so lucky in some cases DDoS
attacks have been used to shut down a
service and then request a ransom from
the owner so how do you protect yourself
well the simple answer is to be ready to
scale and that likely means using a big
cloud provider a service like Google
cloud armor has the bandwidth to handle
attacks like this and it can also
prevent many other attacks that we
talked about earlier in the video but at
the end of the day nobody's application
is 100% safe there are likely hackers
out there right now using zero-day
exploits that we don't know about yet
and it's only a matter of time before
the next major data breach is in the
headlines if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and make sure
to check out the enterprise security
course if you really want to master
these concepts thanks for watching and I
will
talk to you soon
[Music]